foreign
i'm beryl joined by my new co-host asha
hello and this week we're looking at
pizza
we're very excited
[Music]
okay i'm gonna make some pizza too
[Music]
when i was doing my research for this i
have this question like what is pizza
what is pizza yes this is corn
i love it don't at me it's dough
it's cheese usually it has a sauce some
toppings
but i think that pizza can be a lot of
things and things can definitely be
pizza adjacent
enough to be in the pizza club i'm sure
the pizza purists are gonna get upset
because i used a broader definition of
pizza when i put together this episode
but
if you don't eat cheese while you're
making pizza are you even making it
right
anyway i spoke to seven people in seven
countries
to see different interpretations of
pizza around the world
so this is the pizza episode
[Music]
oh my god this pizza's gonna be so good
that looks pretty good i've always
wanted to do the pizza in the oven shot
[Music]
in making this episode i decided two
things one
i'm gonna reiterate it my definition of
pizza is broad
and two no topping is off-limits
none for all of the pizzas that i didn't
cover
and all the toppings we didn't discuss
let me know in the comments where you're
from and what a perfect
pizza is for you and for fun what's one
topping that you just can't get behind
i love corn pizza as you can tell and my
least favorite topping is probably going
to be anchovies
just too salty anyway my pizza's in the
oven
let's get this video started let's get
this pizza party started
[Music]
into
[Music]
the visa in thailand is big but
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
we're starting in mexico with a pizza of
a different hue
nosotros creamos la primera unica pizza
hmm
[Music]
is a concept
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
[Music]
next up is georgia with a dish that does
ask the question
is this pizza either way it's delicious
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
sweden does things a little differently
there any topping is game
including bananas
pizza popular femtomatter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in nepal this dish has a long history
and tradition and then
the youths came added cheese and called
it pizza
[Music]
dinner
publicly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we are heading to tanzania where this
pizza dish draws crowds
half of the pizza but also half for the
chef who is a total delight
i'm a king of disaster pizza i make the
delicious pizza
my name is mohammed elias magengo my
nickname is mr chocolate
i series as barbies in parudhany garden
park
this pizza the original is from in
mombasa
in kenya they call it kima chapati we
call this asma pizza because other
materials is only from zanzibar
for the morning i'm going to the market
then i buy some materials like
karate onion green pepper fresh tomato
banana mango avocado vanilla for the
sweet pizza
the most popular pizza is the beef
cheese and vegetable
i take my flour and the water i mix
after that
i've got the bowl big and small i take
in my chopped chop
and then i put the mayonnaise cheese and
the egg
and then i take the beef with my spiced
masala
and then i mix together then i close for
all sides
i take it and then i put for the
barbecue
that's batisa is the best in the world
before many people they know only
italian pizza
but now there are the jasmine pizza and
italian pizza she's like match
so the pizza is winner
brazilians love pizza but they don't use
mozzarella all the time rather they use
a creamy squeezable cheese that is
totally beloved
[Music]
[Music]
and we end where it all began in italy
the birthplace of pizza with a fried
version
that has an interesting story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my pizza is complete
[Music]
honestly i know people like think corn
can be weird on pizza but like
try it it's so good there are some foods
that are truly universal
they share a same name a feeling a
sentiment pizza is one of them
you can find it everywhere and that is
not just because there's a dominoes
everywhere
but because people have added their own
spin to it
people love it i mean it's bread it's
cheese
it's toppings it's sauce it what is not
to love you know
it's funny because it's this one food
that i think most people
most would say yes i like pizza
and there's not many foods like that out
there pizza is
a gift that's as deep as we're going in
this episode
because it's true though it is a gift
[Music]
they eat pizza every day i love it i
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
you